[Musique]
bonsoir à tous je suis très heureux de
vous retrouver pour ce set vite sport à
l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département a c'est
parti pour le sommaire en football on
prendra la direction de versailles les
versets qui continue l'aventuré en coupe
de france ils ont réussi à s'imposer 2 à
0 à domicile contre les tahitiens de
l'ice dragon plus d'informations ce
magazine cyclisme un grand gala était
organisé ce samedi soir au vélodrome
national de saint quentin en yvelines
il mettait aux prises à des pistards et
des routiers professionnels dans une
ambiance conviviale les détails dans
quelques instants
gymnastique une compétition inter
départementale 2 gr était organisée ce
samedi et dimanche au palais des sports
d'el en cours avec plus de 300 athlètes
inscrits dont 19 sportif d'el encore par
reportage à suivre l'actualité sportive
de la semaine c'est maintenant sur tv à
[Musique]
on commence donc par du football et la
coupe de france versailles le dernier
représentant yves binois dans la
compétition les versailles et se sont
qualifiés pour le 8e tour en s'imposant
à domicile contre les tahitiens de l'ess
dragons des images de mélanie poquet à
montage de julo grandes villes
ce but propulse vers sa huitième tour de
la coupe de france ce dimanche 18
novembre les versaillais ont réussi à se
qualifier face au club tahitien des
dragons ce camp final 2 à 0 on est
satisfait de votre passé de passer le
tour c'est une satisfaction c'était une
chose qu'on avait à coeur de faire et
l'essentiel a été fait deux buts en
première mi temps après on aurait aimé
marquer plus de buts en seconde période
mais bon en tant qu'arrière laquelle il
faut bout c'est ce qu'on voulait
pourtant rien n'a été simple face à des
polynésiens qui ont joué leur chance à
fond malgré un voyage de 16 mille
kilomètres comme sur cette frappe sur le
poteau de l'ancien joueur de ligue 1
rabat rabat 20 heures
on a beaucoup travaillé mais notre
lumière un dessert aujourd'hui c'était
quand même le voir et ne vendre que du
coup aussi compliqué pour nous surtout
quand on vient ici en pleine période
chaude chez nous avec un taux d'humidité
qui passe qui dépasse les 100%
après cette qualification versailles
reste le dernier club ville ou encore en
course dans la compétition le club
n'avait plus atteint le 8e tour de coupe
de france depuis sept ans ça fait
plaisir maintenant on va voir si
on va voir le prochain tirage c'est
notre faveur on voit dans tous les cas
on va essayer de faire un joli parcours
cette année
ça dépend de l'adversaire comme vous
dites qu'on va monter on va y mettre le
coeur le tirage au sort du 8e tour sera
effectué ce mardi 20 novembre à 19h les
versets y et pourrait recevoir un club
de ligue 2 la rencontre se disputera
quant à elle le 8 décembre prochain
toujours en coupe de france laventure
s'arrête au 7e tour pour carrière gré
sion le club qui évolue en première
division de district a été éliminée par
la charité sur loire une équipe de
nationale 3 malgré les quatre divisions
d'écart le petit poucet national s'est
incliné 2 1 après avoir ouvert le score
à 20 minutes de la fin du match par sami
rivière une défaite au goût amer donc
daisy vinuales les événements
rencontreront donc pas un club
professionnel dans cette coupe de france
on ouvre maintenant une page rugby en
promotion honneur montigny le bretonneux
réalise un gros début de saison lésigny
montain se sont une nouvelle fois imposé
24 à 8 contre chilly mazarin une
victoire qui permet aux saint quentinois
d'être dans le trio de tête pour nous
parler du club nous recevons sur ce
plateau le président jacques moreau et
le vice-capitaine des seniors williams
pautrat bonsoir bonsoir je le disais
précédemment
très belle victoire ce week-end will en
we will très belle victoire contre
contre un adversaire difficile qui
descend qui descend de division
d'honneur on s'attendait à un match
difficile il ya eu un gros début de
match de nos adversaires nous étions
menés 8 à 0
et puis baer il ya eu une superbe
réaction de nos joueurs et je pense que
notre jeunesse et notre envie
nous ont presque donner le bonus
offensif en fin de match ce qui aurait
été la cerise sur le gâteau mais on va
déjà prendre ce qu'ils méritent ce qui
nous est tombé dessus
oui c'était si simple que ça ou pas
quand voit le score 24 à 8 on se dit le
match a été simple c'était pas simple du
tout on était menés 8 7 à la mi temps
vent de face on a réussi à sortir avec
un seul point d'écart à la mi-temps en
notre défaveur
et en deuxième mi temps on a réussi à
tenir le ballon mettre notre système de
jeu un peu plus en place
enchaîner les temps de jeu et puis la
différence a été faite aux alentours et
la 60e 65e minute
et voilà on a eu mon a mis la main sur
le ballon on a mis en place que les
coaches nous envier et ça s'est bien
passé mais c'était compliqué alors vous
êtes actuellement 3e du championnat
quatre victoires en six matches est ce
que vous attendiez un début de saison
aussi tonitruant
je ne sais pas montigny on est le petit
club saint quentinois
donc on est assez humbles et ont joué
avec humilité on s'attendait peut-être
pas un début comme ça mais on prend ce
qui à prendre et est maintenant qu'on
est dans le trio de tête on y est bien
et on va faire en sorte d'y rester
président est-ce que vous l'aviez senti
peut-être que cette saison serait une
belle saison pas forcément parce qu'en
plus sur le papier on avait un début
difficile sur les six matches on a fait
quatre à l'extérieur donc je m'attendais
un début difficile et
et en fait tous les matches sont serrés
dans cette poule et ça se passe bien ça
se passe bien le groupe est très solide
il ya un très très bon esprit dans
l'équipe
effectivement comme l'a dit william en
est 3e on va prendre on va y aller
doucement mais troisième ça serait bien
cinq points qui séparent le cinquième du
championnat du premier est-ce qu'il
fallait cette victoire forcément ce
week-end pour rester dans le wagon de
tête on va dire complètement la semaine
dernière vraiment le droit à l'erreur
finalement dans ce championnat on peut
avoir le droit à l'erreur
peut-être pas tous les week-ends et qui
plus est la semaine dernière où on perd
quand un prétendant direct aux premières
places aulnay qui plus est à domicile
donc on se devait de rebondir
directement avec une victoire chez un
concurrent qui est pas très loin
derrière nous au classement et et pour
rester pour rester en quoi et en plus de
ça où on reçoit chez nous la semaine
prochaine par xo qui est deuxième de la
poule donc on devait de gagner pour se
maintenir pour se maintenir en haut du
classement on a parlé un petit peu
cutter dans l'entretien à vous en êtes
seulement votre deuxième saison dans ce
championnat de promotion honneur
est ce que vous attendiez à finalement
rivaliser avec vos adversaires du haut
du tableau
très franchement non pas le haut de
tableau on a été on était parti et fait
on était planté pour notre deuxième
saison que quelque part la fin de la
saison c'était l'année du maintien mon
amie on a mis dix ans pour monter la
première série à la promotion d'honneur
on a échoué quatre fois à la montée en
promotion d'honneur
donc on voulait surtout pas redescendre
tout de suite l'année dernière et on a
fait un beau parcours on a terminé 6e
sur 10 cette année l'objectif c'est
d'essayer d'être dans la première moitié
pour l'instant on nier et c'est vrai que
si on verra ce que la suite du
championnat nous réserve mais si les
garçons continuent à gagner des matches
on va on va voir ce qui va arriver
william qu'est ce qui fait la force du
club c'est ça ce tapis et stabilité
peut-être c'est un club quand même assez
stable avec des coachs qui sont là
depuis de nombreuses saisons
ouais tout à fait et comme je vous ai
tout à l'heure on est on est le petit
club saint quentinois on nous critique
de temps en temps parce qu'on reste
l'entité montigny mais on y est bien on
est un club familial
tous les joueurs du groupe seniors on se
connaît pour la plupart depuis 10 15 ans
on est entre amis on est entre copains
quand les joueurs nous rejoignent ils
s'y sentent bien tout de suite dans cet
esprit familial et forcément je pense
que ces prix là cette alchimie ça se
ressent sur le terrain
sur la qualité du jeu qu'on peut
proposer est ce qu'on seront qu'on
essaye de montrer de 100 points c'est
votre idée aussi votre ligne directrice
pour pour faire grandir le club d'avoir
une stabilité
oui des joueurs en club stade on a
effectivement des entraîneurs qui sont
là maintenant puis nombreuses années et
du coup elle le plein des systèmes de
jeu sont bien connus des joueurs
la plupart de joueurs ont été formés
dans notre école de rugby la plupart ont
commencé à 6 ans 7 ans 8 ans chez nous à
dose homéopathique
il ya des nouveaux joueurs qui arrivent
qui s'intègre très facilement je pense
que c'est une des qualités de notre
groupe c'est qu'il est très accueillant
on s'y sent bien en fait dans ce club
et oui notre idée c'est de progresser
petit à petit
ça se traduit en promotion d'honneur et
puis on verra vous fixez quel objectif
cette année cette année leur éthique si
j'avais dû tout à l'heure c'est la
première main la première moitié de la
poule c'est à dire dans les cinq connaît
pas plus au top pas plus haut nous on ne
fait pas des déclarations nous y lit
avant que si on peut être troisième à la
fin on sera content et de revenir à
jouer en championnat de france
mais le fait de faire des grandes
déclarations ça n'entraîne pas forcément
des grands résultats donc dû monter
c'est jouable ou pas cette année
williams comme l'a dit le président et
comme je milite et et on essaiera de
faire parler de nous en fin de saison
alors vous allez jouer ce dimanche
contre paris à domicile un pronostic
avant de se quitter donc on a un point
de plus à la fin du match et 6 contre
pareil pour vous président l'avait mangé
une victoire moi je crois vraiment qu'on
peut gagner
ok merci à tous les deux passés sur ce
plateau vous souhaite bonne chance pour
la suite de la saison et on vous
souhaite à vous avez un petit mot je
veux juste ajouter un petit mot là
puisque le rugby on parle beaucoup de
rugby masculin qui marche pas si bien
que je fais actuellement mais le rugby
féminin marche très très bien il ya eu
un remarquable exploit des féminines de
l'équipe de france samedi la contredit
les landes et je voulais surtout dire
que on a une section féminine très
active dans notre dans notre club on est
le seul club des yvelines à avoir une
équipe en division fédérale et on
accueille à bras ouverts tout sportive
débutante dans le rugby ou non
confirmées en rugby et ce qui est ce qui
a été dit pour les garçons est également
très vrai pour les filles
on est très accueillant vous recrutez et
on recrute
le message est passé merci à tous d'être
passé sur ce bateau renferme cette page
rugby par deux résultats tout d'abord
dans le championnat de division honneur
6e journée versailles ne s'arrête plus
les joueurs de la cité royale toujours
invaincus dans ce championnat se sont
imposés assez facilement 24 à 3 face à
l'ennemi rugby une victoire qui permet
aux versets de prendre le large et de
compter maintenant six points d'avancé
sur le second montesson la montée
l'objectif annoncé du club semble se
dessiner
toujours dans le championnat honneur de
cette fois ci dans la poule 2 le sky
rugby n'a pas réussi à s'imposer ce
week-end sur le teint du multisports
bagneux rugby et saint quentinois se
sont inclinés dimanche 17 à 14
une défaite lourde de conséquence le sky
redescend à la septième place et
pointent désormais à 11 points de la
première place les joueurs auront
l'occasion de se rattraper à ce dimanche
à domicile contre le red star hameau de
voile et de la route du rhum à présent
levé les versets le versailles et éric
bellion continua sa route pour rejoindre
la guadeloupe l'illinois est
actuellement au large de l'espagne après
avoir laissé passer la tempête au
classement ils pointent à la 10e place
avec sa goélette en bois hors catégorie
même si pour lui l'essentiel est
d'arriver à bon port il a enregistré un
message depuis son bateau il semble
aimer à son voyage
du cyclisme à présent direction le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines un grand gala
baptisé star en piste était organisée ce
samedi soir dans la structure le concept
des professionnels de la piste ont
affronté à affronter des routards sur à
différentes épreuves dans une ambiance
bon enfant devant plus de 3000 personnes
on écoute les réactions au micro de
mélanie poké c'est une bonne chose c'est
une bonne chose parce que déjà y'a pas
beaucoup d'événements populaires et
festifs en france voilà avec des
coureurs de renom
c'est une belle soirée une belle épreuve
vraiment beaucoup de plaisir
on profite on est plusieurs plusieurs
coureurs à se retrouver simple inédit
donc c'est bon ça reste la même
discipline c'est du vélo il ya des roues
c'est l'occasion d'échanger de partager
voilà n'ont ressenti c'est vrai que moi
j'ai un peu d'appréhension en roulant en
peloton sur piste ce qui n'est pas le
cas sur route ce que je quelqu'un une
nouvelle édition pourrait être organisée
dans les approches un mois en reste au
vélodrome nationale 2 à saint quentin en
yvelines jeudi dernier le cycliste
philippe pons et malades des poumons a
réussi l'exploit de boucler les 200 m
lancé sur la piste en moins de 15
secondes pour réaliser cette performance
semblable à un sprint à plus de 8000
mètres d'altitude
ce savoyard s'est entraîné deux heures
par jour depuis juillet dernier
avec ce record à philippe pons et espère
sensibiliser le grand public sur sa
maladie des poumons là à bpce une
maladie qui touche environ 4 millions de
français ont louvre maintenant une page
découvert dans ce set 8 sport notre
journaliste marylène heye à piché au
nous a rejoint sur ce plateau bonsoir
alors marylène nous présentera chaque
mois des sports méconnus
ce soir marylène vous allez vous faire
découvrir une discipline le krav maga
alors j'ai bien dit discipline et non
aux sports calloch krav maga
c'est pas facile à dire n'est pas un
sport effectivement michael le krav maga
est méthode d'atteinte défensif qui nous
vient directement des forces militaires
israéliennes
il n'y a pas de règles pas de respect de
l'adversaire et sage et d'apprendre à
répondre à une attaque eric salem sait
de quoi il parle cet ancien des unités
spéciales d'intervention de la
gendarmerie a décidé d'enseigner ces
techniques de défense au civil en créant
son école énergie défense une agression
au couteau
on a pu rencontrer
la capitale et ailleurs on va essayer de
se sortir de là a une âme une défense
une attaque qui va être proportionnelle
à la propre à pâques on est en train de
subir
donc effectivement sur la une attaque au
couteau bon bah on va parler bonbons par
une attaque au couteau évidemment mais
on va être on va se donner les moyens
d'être est très efficace et c'est ouvert
à tout le monde alors sur le principe
oui merci
wells au principe parce que
l'instructeur se réserve le droit de
vous demander votre casier judiciaire
s'il vous sous peine de venir pour de
mauvaises raisons
si au départ beaucoup d'hommes
s'inscrivaient pour se défouler
aujourd'hui l'école comprend
pratiquement 50% de femmes nathalie
salem s'occupe des cours réservés aux
femmes
objectif prendre confiance en soi c'est
pas que la self défense c'est à dire
qu'on contre attaque d'accord pour
justement se sortir d'une situation il
faut oser contre-attaqué donc faut avoir
une certaine confiance en soi pour
justement contre attaque et on apprend à
frapper alors que c'est pareil mais et
vous avez justement essayer marylène et
je crois que vous êtes plutôt bien
débrouillé jesse may montré trois gestes
de base pour me dégager d'un agresseur
et vous allez voir qu'en plus il ne m'a
pas ménagé
[Musique]
la main qui a été saisie va venir par
dessous est tout simplement avec l'autre
main
[Musique]
serons nous étrangle vous allez vouloir
respirer m donc exact et simultanément
les frapper ok ça qu'on est là
en réponse m en retrait bien poussé
poussé à l'élite
[Musique]
et
partir en fumée
alors là ce veut venir sauter dans le
train pour repartir d'un côté et si vous
voulez vous y mettre vous aussi énergie
défense propose des cours mixtes aux
sportifs sporting de guyancourt
vous pouvez également prendre des cours
particuliers plusieurs renseignements
sur leur site internet ce qui s'affiche
justement l'écran on y réfléchir à deux
fois avant de faire des blagues en
rédaction en tout cas marylène merci
beaucoup on vous retrouvera le mois
prochain sur ceux à 7,8 sport on prend
maintenant la direction à d'elancourt
une compétition régionale 2 gr
gymnastique rythmique était organisée ce
week-end au palais des sports avec plus
de 300 athlètes un montage de romain
respini des images de à mélanie poquet
des cerceaux des ballons et des figures
spectaculaires bienvenue sur cette
compétition interdépartemental de gr le
rendez vous était organisée cette année
par le club d'elancourt bord pas sur
deux jours les 17 et 18 novembre au
palais des sports des longs cours il ya
quatre départements
pas forcément tous les clubs donc c'est
vraiment mélanger il ya 4
lieu en ile-de-france qui fondent et
interdépartementale et il ya à peu près
3 125 gymnastes il ya tous les âges de
dix ans jusqu'à plus de 18 ans je sais
pas quel âge à la dernière et c'est par
catégorie alors il ya catégories d'âge
et catégories de niveau parmi les 320
gymnastes présence certains se sont
entraînés pendant plusieurs mois pour
être prêts à le jour j beaucoup
d'entraînement parce qu'il va forcément
s'entraîner ça prend du temps
j'ai bien détaillé tout le monde
enchaînement partie par partie
trois cours par semaine et ça fait six
heures par semaine de cours et puis
c'est quand même beaucoup pour réaliser
des performances de haut niveau les 19
compétiteurs du club d'elancourt
maurepas ont voulu profiter de
l'avantagé d'évoluer à domicile on a
l'habitude de s'entraîner sur les
praticables à voir c'est un peu plus
simple le club deal en cours maurepas
est finalement ressorti de la
compétition avec sept podiums dont
quatre premières places la structure
pourrait de nouveau accueillir la
compétition l'année prochaine
on passe maintenant notre page agenda on
commence cette page agenda par de la
gymnastique la nouvelle vient de tomber
chez le club d'elancourt maurepas va
organiser les championnats de france
national par équipe les 24 25 et 26 mai
prochains vélodrome nationale 2 à saint
quentin en yvelines pour nous parler de
cette nouvelle nous recevons sur ce
plateau
la vice présidente de la gemme morgan
poulard bonsoir ainsi que deux athlètes
du club de zilli le riche et flavie
d'enfer bonsoir alors comment vous avez
accueilli cette nouvelle
et bien en fait on a des visées
candidature en fin de saison cette année
donc on a une réponse de la fédération
française de gymnastique cet été qui
nous a donc sélectionné pour organiser
ce championnat de france après il a
fallu trouver le lieu est confirmé que
ça allait bien se faire au vélodrome
nationale et voilà ça s'est déroulé la
lia la semaine dernière on a enfin si et
pourquoi vous avez décidé du coup de
postuler alors ça fait un moment que la
question se pose
ça fait un an ou deux qu'on y
réfléchisse
c'est vrai que là on est lancé on s'est
dit pourquoi pas cette année ça va nous
permettre d'une part de faire rayonner
club de fédérer aussi nos équipes de
bénévoles
ça fait 20 ans ça s'est pas fait en
ile-de-france donc pour le coup c'est
une aventure dans laquelle on part des
comment vous avez accueilli à cette
nouvelle du coup au club compte parce
que il n'y avait pas de déplacement fin
on en connaît les agressent à la maison
ouais voilà à domicile même chose pour
toi oui
morgane du coup vous vous disiez ça
faisait 20 ans que ce n'était pas revenu
en ile-de-france pourquoi alors pourquoi
j'ai parce que j'ai pas la réponse mais
oui cette idée habituellement ça
s'organise souvent en province et c'est
souvent dans des parcs d'exposition des
des gros complexe et c'est vrai qu'en
ile-de-france ont manqué un peu de ça et
notamment la sur saint quentin en
yvelines l'arrivée du vélodrome a fait a
fait du bien et c'est vrai que là on
manque de salle qui peut accueillir ce
type d'événement de parking autour de
deux structures qui sont faites pour ça
et le vélodrome ben va nous permettre
normalement de faire cet événement
correct et comment vous avez fait pour
pour les séduire justement oui j'adore
le vélodrome et le comité et ben écoutez
je pense que il ya d'une part la
nouveauté le fait que ça fait longtemps
que ça s'est pas fait en ile de france
d'autre part le fait que le vélodrome
soit un lieu de paris 2024 pour le coup
je pense que ça a plu à la fédération
française de gymnastique
et puis le vélodrome verizon n'a jamais
accueilli de gymnastique donc peut-être
que c'est une première pour eux aussi
alors il y aura combien de personnes du
koursk vélodrome est ce qu'on pouvait
nous donner les gros chiffres
alors on attend mille quatre cents
gymnastes sur les trois jours qui seront
qui font la compétition
et on espère atteindre 5000 personnes
sur cet événement en spectateur est ce
que vous pensez vous serez favorite sur
cette compétition on espère mais non
vous avez quand même réalisé des
championnats de france en passer
et du coup est-ce que vous avez assez
d'expérience du coup la toile un peu
mais pas énormément non plus et toujours
le stress oui tiens justement parlant de
stress skis elle ce stress de
compétition à domicile
alors pour elle je sais pas mais pour
nous organisateurs oui forcément une
grosse avance c'est un gros challenge
pour nous pour toute l'équipe de
bénévoles qui a au club donc
donc oui c'est stressant pour nous et
c'est vrai que forcément on est devant
la maison devant notre public entre
guillemets et nos familles nos amis donc
pour elle je pense que ce sera ça peut
être un bon stress positif les bourses
et un petit peu parce que ça va vous
booster est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec morgan gould
il y aura toujours du stress mais ce
sera le même que
dans les autres compétitions une manière
là toujours du stress quand on fait des
compétitions et comment il faut il faut
l'appréhender
justement cette compétition à votre avis
et morgane prennent pour elle en tant
que pont en tant que sportive je pense
que forcément au début ça va être un peu
impressionnant parce que le complexe est
assez assez impressionnant l ont pas
l'habitude mais après voilà faut qu'elle
aborde comme n'importe quel compte est
comme quand on se déplace sur un
championnat de france de faire
puisqu'elle safer comme à l'entraînement
du mieux qu'elles peuvent et voilà et je
pense qu'en effet il faut qu'elle prenne
toutes ces énergies de toute leur
famille leurs amis qui seront là où
forcément il n'y aura plus que
d'habitude de façon positive et que ça
leur donne un petit coup de boost et
elles ont l'habitude d'aller sur des
cheveux de france
oui bah vous pouvez en parler vous avez
un journal de france l'année dernière
oui et comment comment du coup on
travaille autour de ce type d'événement
quand on est encadrée on va dire
est-ce qu'on multiplie peut-être les
séances de travail peut-être avant une
méchante comme celle là où il forcément
là où actuelle combien
actuellement on est en période de
recrutement de bénévoles on a lancé un
appel à candidatures sur nos réseaux
sociaux par mail etc
on ambitionne alors nous on a une
adresse minky club j'aime 78 @ gmail
point com voilà on a aussi une page
facebook un site et ses terrasses et on
ambitionne de recruter 150 bénévoles sur
cet événement donc là
on reçoit les candidatures et on a une
première grosse réunion le 29 novembre
au vélodrome
on va accueillir tous ces bénévoles et
commencer un peu la répartition en
commission par par thématique et après
forcément les réunions vont s'enchaîner
par commission jusqu'à jusqu'au jour j
et sur les entraînements pour pro a pour
elle s'achète à changera pas grand chose
normalement le but c'est d'ailleurs que
ça change rien à part le fait qu'elle
soit plus en confiance parce que c'est à
domicile mais normalement leur
entraîneur les prépare comme pour tout
championnat de france que parce que vous
appréhendez un petit peu cette charge de
travail supplémentaire à cette pression
dans l'habitude vous entraînez combien
de fois par semaine et combien d'heures
cinq fois par semaine à peu près 18 à
20h 18h 20h05 fois par semaine et là où
pensez que vous allez encore en faire
plus peut-être oui l approche vous visez
un certain nombre de médailles ou pas du
tout sur ce que vous avez déjà une idée
en tête non on vise pas de fin
on vend pas la peau de l'ours avant de
l'avoir tué et on ne fait pas le match
avant d'avoir fait et voilà elles vont
donner le meilleur de ce qu'elles
peuvent
on a aura plusieurs équipes normalement
qui participeront à ces championnats de
france
maintenant voilà c'est une médaille là
on sera les premiers avis et du premier
à fêter ça mais voilà
et l'objectif à terme c'est forcément
d'attirer de nouveaux licenciés aussi au
club
oui aujourd'hui on a 450 adhérents au
club licenciés bien sûr que l'ambition
c'est de se développer
maintenant
il faut aussi que les structures
puissent le permettre en termes de
gymnase d'entraînement en termes
d'horaires etc etc
merci à toutes les trois lettres passé
sur ce plateau morgan goût là on vous
souhaite bon courage pour l'organisation
et vous azélie et flavie plein de
médailles en mai prochain
merci beaucoup on continue cet agenda
par de l'aa capoeira le club de belo
horizonte d'elancourt organise des
rencontres internationales au palais des
sports ce samedi 24 novembre de 9h à 18h
cette journée permettra à ses adhérents
de passer leur grade devant une
trentaine de professionnels venus de
france et d'europe
si vous voulez assister à ce rendez vous
l'entrée est libre et on termine à part
du football en première division de
district le club de plaisir reçoit du en
cours pour un derby à sulfureux dans le
stade bernard giroux et deux équipes
sont au coude à coude dans ce
championnat et ne sont séparés que par 3
petits points après 8 journées
l'ambiance s'annonce électrique sur le
bord du terrain
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi
rendez vous lundi prochain pour un
nouveau magazine d'ici là passez une
excellente semaine sportive très belle
soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]